stephen f hayward is the fk wirehouser
fellow at the american enterprise
institute a fellow at the claremont
institute and a senior fellow at the
pacific research institute he received
his phd in american studies from the
claremont graduate school
he is the author of scores of articles
on public policy and numerous books on
statesmanship including a two-volume
political biography of ronald reagan
each year for over 15 years he has
co-authored the index of leading
environmental indicators
today he will be speaking on the topic
the epa and private property please join
me in welcoming stephen f hayward
well thanks very much and it's uh it's
wonderful to be here at the kirby center
it's my first visit
uh and i want to especially thank david
bob for his
really polite and generous depiction of
my uh attention deficit disorder uh
how else do you explain you know reagan
and the epa
well there's a couple of explanations
one is is that i sometimes say that i do
environmental work
because somebody has to take out the
trash right
but i only do it about
no more than about half of my time
because i like to say if i actually
spent full time working on environmental
issues i would surely die from
self-inflicted wounds before old age
there's so much craziness in the field
right but more directly i can i can find
a connection for you
being a native californian i remember
that wonderful moment in the 1980
campaign when ronald reagan made a
comment about trees cause pollution
much to the horror and shock of well
everybody right especially the the news
media
uh he was actually visiting the
claremont colleges where i was about to
start graduate school at the time on a
smoggy day in the fall
and the students would put up signs
saying on trees saying stop me before i
kill again and you're sort of mocking
the president now it turns out that
then governor reagan candidate reagan
was completely right about that subject
he had a little out of proportion but he
was essentially correct about the the
role of you know naturally occurring
pollutants especially nitrogen oxides
that contribute to the ozone problem
and you can find if you look around far
enough on the epa website their own
research into what they call biogenic
emissions they're embarrassed about this
they don't like to admit it but it's
there
and so the gipper was right once again
and that's all the connection i need to
draw
between work on ronald reagan and the
epa
uh so i was
asked to uh to talk about a slightly
different avenue of approach but one
that i think is getting more important
which as was advertised the epa and
property rights or private property
coterminous terms of course so i want to
begin to frame this discussion with four
propositions and then we'll work through
them
in series and see if we can't try a few
reforms at the end
one of the reasons we're in such trouble
is that reforms are not simple and not
perfect
well so i'll come to that broad framing
in a moment the the first proposition i
want to make is that the primary threat
to private property over the last
century or more
has come mostly from the actions of
state and local government more so than
the federal government and it's usually
in the form of excessive zoning
regulations and abuses of the eminent
domain power
and these abuses were enabled and
abetted by the judiciary's abdication as
a protector of property rights
over the course of
over the course of a century
and this has opened the way to mischief
from the federal level now there have
been some partial victories in the
courts on this front in recent years but
there's still a very long way to go and
this will turn out to be one of the
central problems that we face as we go
forward
the second proposition is about the
nature of the epa the epa at its
founding
and certainly for its first couple of
decades for the most part and to a large
extent still today
should be thought of really as just a
supercharged public health agency
they wouldn't necessarily describe their
mission that way they think their
mission is to save the earth but really
their public health agency
its main mission at its origin was to
protect environmental threats to public
health and chiefly in 1970 that meant
giant smoke stacks automobile tail pipes
large sources of effluents into our
major rivers and water bodies
and that meant in large part by the way
getting local governments to upgrade
their sewage treatment programs so the
problem was as much
government as it was private industry or
you know the chemical factory of the new
yorker cartoons dumping stuff into a
river or lake some of that went on but
but a large part of it was local
government problems
with only a few exceptions the epa in
those years was not much concerned with
or much of a threat to private property
with the exception very early on of
superfund sites
or things like superfund sites that
involved toxic pollution or toxic waste
and things of that kind the endangered
species act which david referred to
is the province primarily of the fish
and wildlife service in the department
of the interior so the main trouble
there doesn't come from epa although
sometimes epa gets implicated in
endangered species act cases through the
typical interagency permit process hell
this leads to my third proposition which
is that the threat to property rights
has started to invert from state and
local government up to the federal
government
in general from the federal government
david made reference to you know
kangaroo rats in california
but lately the problem has been the
federal government saying to farmers in
the central valley forget about your
rats you don't get any water
that you historically had rights to for
a century
maybe even a property right one might
say even though that's a murky and
complicated problem
and the epa is expanding its reach
further into private property questions
and the chief vehicle to do this is the
clean water act about which more in a
moment
my fourth proposition
is that this entire problem cannot or
should not be viewed in isolation from
the broader problem of the breakdown of
the separation of powers that's a
century-long story uh the delegation of
the author of authority by congress to
the bureaucracy
and the perversion of administrative law
today this is what scholars at hillsdale
our friends at the heritage foundation
across the street and others refer to as
the problem of the administrative state
so hence our remedies or reforms in the
service of protecting property rights
will need to be conceived i think within
a broader framework of restoring the
proper constitutional balance between
the branches
across the board as well as
constitutional restraints on certain
kinds of government activity so let's
work through these propositions in turn
the erosion of property rights
protection in general is a long story
entangled story and i don't propose to
recall even in summary form the entire
constitutional history today that would
take too long and you'd all fall asleep
i think but there are a few modern
scenes worth noting that can sharpen our
focus on a couple of essential matters
i'd like to point to two modern supreme
court cases
one is new orleans v dukes from 1976
and the second is mid kif versus hawaii
housing authority in 1984.
some people know a bit about the midkiff
cases purely a property rights case the
first one new orleans v dukes is not
on the surface a property rights case
but shows a problem in a broader scale
the duke's case involved a woman named
nancy dukes who sold hot dogs from a
push cart in the french quarter in new
orleans
and she'd been doing it for about two
years when the new orleans city council
passed an ordinance
that said achieve a license for the push
card it revoked all licenses for push
carts from anyone who had not been
selling hot dogs from push carts for at
least eight years
it sounds like a neutral condition
except that ordinance had the effect of
only putting a single person out of
business nancy dukes this was clearly an
ordinance that was uh promulgated to
some favored people maybe payoffs
involved who knows you hear that kind of
thing happens in new orleans once in a
while right
uh and so nancy dukes sued and the case
made its way to the supreme court
she claimed the violation of equal
protection of the laws and you know due
process claims which really the courts
haven't smiled upon for a very long time
and the supreme court ruled unanimously
in favor of the city of new orleans so
nancy dukes lost her case
and in ruling for the city the supreme
court said
among other things quote
when local economic regulation is
challenged solely as violating the equal
protection clause
this court consistently defers to
legislative determination
as to the desirability of a particular
statutory determination
the court added that we will not sit as
a super legislature to judge the wisdom
or desirability of legislative policy
determinations made in areas that
neither affect fundamental rights nor
proceed along suspect lines
close quote by the end by the way that
bit about suspect lines what does they
mean well that's civil rights cases
those of you students and others who
done your constitutional history
will know that ever since the dubious
caroline products case of 1938 supreme
court has said there are two classes of
rights there are economic rights which
includes property rights and then there
are your civil and political rights and
we have two standards we have what they
call either legislative deference or
essentially the legislature can do
whatever it wants in congress and then
there's strict scrutiny if someone's
going to
restrict your freedom of speech or
freedom of religion
we're going to make sure they have a
really good reason for it
so to put in plain english the court has
reached this two-tiered standard where
for economic regulation and economic
rights court says we're not going to
bother you very much whereas for
political rights we'll bother you a lot
you don't need any reason at all really
or you need a whole lot of good reasons
i don't think you need to be very
inventive to suggest that there is no
way that you can divine any intelligible
principle from the text of the
constitution for that distinction that
is one the court has made up now i could
have picked other cases there's a lot of
them like this going back over the you
know over the years back into the 1940s
uh williamson optical out of out of
oklahoma in 1952 is another egregious
case of this kind but the reason this
one is fun i think is
in a good way of illustrating this as
and why i like a case out of the french
quarter is suppose as a thought
experiment
that nancy dukes had been a new dancer
in the french quarter i hear they have
some of those there
and or to modify it
and so instead of a hot dog vendor she'd
been a new dancer at some place of
entertainment and suppose the city of
new orleans had passed an ordinance that
targeted her to prevent her from plying
her trade around the polls
she would have she would have won her
case on the grounds that her free
expression under the first amendment was
being violated right
uh you know irving crystal famously
remarked the jurisprudence of free
expression uh that quote it's okay for a
16 year old to dance naked on stage as
long as you pay her the minimum wage
today he'd add obviously and provide her
health insurance and contraception
this by the way raises the possibility
that nancy dukes was not inventive
enough she should have been a naked hot
dog vendor
that would have crossed the streams of
the supreme court justices
since chief justice john paul roberts as
i'm calling him now wasn't yet on the
scene to advise the court on the
possibilities of the taxing clause
um
the the point is is it is obviously
incoherent to us to have a judicial
doctrine uh that says that uh the right
to make a living
is not as fundamental as your right to
speak
and certainly property is implicated in
that too right
uh the second case i mentioned uh is a
mid-kit versus hawaii housing authority
the 1984 case this involved the
legislative scheme to use the power of
eminent domain in hawaii essentially to
confiscate the land i mean they're going
to pay the you know compensation the way
that the taxing clause requires
but then to give the land to other
people
not for public use see usually eminent
domain was meant you're going to take
the land for a road a military base
a baseball stadium is even though if
it's privately owned is arguably public
use because the public gets to go there
but in this case they weren't going to
take the land for
some public use the way that phrases
meant by common sense but they wanted to
redistribute the land because the
problem in hawaii was that 90 of the
land was owned by one company dating
back into the 19th century in the way
the island was settled right
in that case
the the court decided unanimously again
in favor of the state of hawaii to use
the power of eminent domain not for
taking land for public use but for as
the court put it a public purpose
right and the unanimous decision the
majority opinion majority the unanimous
opinion was written by sandra day
o'connor
and recognized that the court at that
time didn't yet have justice scalia but
had william rehnquist and he was part of
this nine zero majority
now between then and now there have been
some significant property rights
victories at the supreme court there was
the nolan case in 1987
where justice scalia then newly on the
court said that the california coastal
commission could not practice extortion
in the issuance of building permits to
individual landowners and in 1992 there
was the lucas case out of south carolina
uh which said that uh the city of south
the state of south carolina couldn't
render someone's land valueless through
regulation that was a pretty extreme
case and a pretty easy one
and those were good but they didn't
really know go far enough they were
narrow cases as so often is the case
now fast forward to the 2005 case that
many of you are probably familiar with
of kilo versus the city of new london
out of connecticut
once again this was a public purpose
case if you remember the facts of the
case
suzanne kelow had a nice house down near
the water wasn't a blighted neighborhood
and the city wanted to condemn her house
and the others in the neighborhood to
give the land not for a stadium not for
a firehouse or a police station or road
or even a municipal parking lot
but to give it to a large corporation
which wanted to expand its headquarters
and the public purpose justification was
well it will expand our tax base we'll
get more tax money out of it that way
and
the surprise of this case to many legal
observers was first that the court took
the case at all
they thought based on precedence like
the mid-kiff case and others
you know i can't imagine they'll be
lucky to get more than clarence thomas's
vote on a case like this right
instead
they got four votes this really did
surprise people that came that close the
defector was the usual one justice
kennedy
and moreover the very strong dissent in
the case saying that ms kilo should have
won the case was written by
sandra day o'connor then about to leave
the court so you can see that
you know sometimes these people get a
little better it's not always a one-way
street the wrong way
and then there's the more recent case
that some of you may have heard of the
sacket case which represents a small
step in the right direction although
very small this is a case from just the
last few months and i want to come back
to that case in a little bit
so hold the second thought for a moment
the second
proposition i was making so to summarize
the first point is is that our
the constitutional protection of
property rights
by the judiciary is exceedingly weak
there's a couple of tiny bright spots
but that's been a a sad hundred year
long story
about which we should still be
complaining very loudly
the second proposition was about the epa
um
as i said that it was originally
public health agency in 1970 aimed at
genuine
significant pollution problems i grew up
in l.a when i couldn't breathe in the
summertime
and and setting aside for the moment the
cost of epa regulation
i'll pause here to say that i'd like to
say that the epa specialty is devising
billion dollar solutions to million
dollar problems
although
a lot of people tell me oh you've got
that way off it's more like 10 billion
dollar solutions to million dollar
product that's probably right they're
the best at it in government they're the
farthest out of whack of anybody we'll
say more about that in a moment but
setting aside the cost of epa
regulations and the often perverse
process by which they do it
about which i can bore you silly for a
long time
we've gotten impressive results
from our environmental objectives
right we have enormous reductions in air
pollution
i like to say that it may come as soon
as my children are going to say but
certainly my grandchildren will say smog
what was that
even true of l.a by the way so when i
was growing up in la
this town used to violate the city the
basin used to violate the
uh the one hour ozone standard almost
200 days a year
for the last 10 years it seldom violated
the old one hour ozone standard more
than 10 days a year
and actually that's not even the whole
basin that's just a couple of isolated
places
for the majority of the population of
the los angeles basin their exposure to
days above the one hour ozone standard
for the last 10 years has been zero or
close to zero in 10 years that's
something to celebrate
even while we reserve our right to be
critical of all the
wrong-headed ways the epa has gone about
this and especially the local regulators
in california who
actually the epa and oddway is
irrelevant to california in some ways
but that's a that's a separate story
other things can be pointed out in water
pollution
i will add for those who are curious i
can talk about this subject for a long
time
but the real hero of the study is not so
much uh the story it's not so much the
epa
or even the landmark legislation but it
really is technology
one of the things about
the modern environmental movement is
they really do seem to have the
mentality of the second star track
series where the captain would say make
it so and it would happen magically
because it's science fiction and the
environmental mentality is if we mandate
it it will just happen well
the story that's never told is all the
technology and regulatory mandates that
had to be abandoned because they weren't
possible the ones that worked are the
ones where
engineers in the private sector figured
out ways to devise much more efficient
ways of combusting fuel
efficient cost-effective ways of
capturing pollution and so forth the
real heroes of environmental progress
are engineers not environmental lawyers
i'm always amused that uh whenever you
hear that somebody is a senior scientist
of natural resources defense counsel
then you look at their degree it's
usually a jd from harvard
okay
i think lawsuits are the way we improve
the environment no it's engineers
and why students are sometimes
disappointed when i say if you're
seriously interested in environment
study science and become an engineer
that's not what they want to hear they
want to become crusaders to save the
planet they want to be rachel carson
right
okay
now i think a case could be made that
based on this progress
that the original epa is obsolete
and that the epa today should be shrunk
or maybe even shut down as we did with
the interstate commerce commission and
the civil aeronautics board that
outlived their usefulness or that most
of its tasks should be devolved to the
states and local government
even though they already are in a
certain way
instead according to the well-known
internal logic of bureaucratic behavior
the epa is looking for ever smaller
monsters to destroy
and are seeking out ever smaller
increments of reduced health risk and in
reality no reduced health risk at all
from recent proposed measures
at ever increasing cost and
intrusiveness
the classic case right now is what's
known as the boilermakt rules as they're
called in the trade mack is maximum
achievable control technology in the
jargon if you're not familiar with it
and you know what these rules
essentially say is well we've got to
squeeze mercury out of everything even
though mercury missions are so tiny as
to be almost undetectable and moreover
because there is no evidence in the
government's own health statistics that
there are any health risks from mercury
to anyone and the epa in their fine
print even acknowledges this but that
doesn't slow them down a bit
this is one of those little wrinkles
they claim huge benefits from the
boilermakt rules and reducing mercury
and a couple other
pollutants
but none of the benefits are from
reducing mercury
all the benefits are from reducing other
kinds of conventional pollution which we
already have regulatory programs for so
why are they going ahead with this
they're going ahead with it for the
usual reasons that bureaucracies
become single-minded by their nature
uh believing it that what they're doing
is the most important thing to happen in
the world
and they're resistant to trade-offs or
even considerations of trade-offs of any
kind
but more specifically the clean water
act has become the main wedge by which
the epa is now threatening private
property
so the the clean water act as it was
written back in the 70s talks about and
the key phrase is
reducing pollution to the navigable
waters of the united states
well now silly us you probably think
navigable waters means things like you
know rivers that you put a boat in or
lakes
great lakes uh well
along the way environmentalists in the
epa said well
but you know
to prevent pollution in this article
this argument is not completely
insensible but but i'm not sure it's
what congress understood was going to
happen when they passed the clean water
act argument was if you're going to
prevent pollution to the mississippi
river or the ohio river or smaller
rivers you've got to worry about their
little tributaries and little creeks and
you need to worry about wetlands where
water runs off from rain periodically
into the so in other words you couldn't
reduce pollution or navigable waters
unless we also extend our regulatory
reach to what we might call for
shorthand unnavigable waters which means
all of them
as a practical matter and the
the courts looked at this and said we
see nothing here that bothers us
and so the epa for a very long time as
you know has been in the business of
regulating wetlands plus other agencies
army corps of engineers has a large role
in this for odd reasons
uh um one question is
this argument about a little creek or a
tributary into a larger river that goes
in the mississippi that makes some sense
that's not a ridiculous idea
um
but what about a wetland what is a
wetland um
you know it's not sufficient to do it
the way the supreme court did with
pornography i know it when i see it no
we've got a little phone book size thing
to define what a wetland is
and even with an attempt to do sort of
rigidly detailed legal specifications
uh you still have the case that there's
a lot of play in the joints a lot of
room for arbitrary determinations by epa
and local government and other agencies
and
you'd be surprised some of the things
that end up being called wetlands and
subject to regulation
now the epa has lost some ground in this
area
not entirely unlike the obamacare case
and the commerce clause for the
individual mandate
the epa lost a case a few years ago uh
involving uh you know sort of
what was that the swank case it was
called this was you know sort of ponds
that were seasonal that never ran off
into anything right out of illinois or
they were just combined in a single
state
by the way because the justification of
the clean water act is interstate
commerce
so in a couple of places they've been
limited but not much
and some of the arguments in favor of
this expansive regulation were pretty
uh
ridiculous yeah one of them was called
the glancing geese test well you know if
a migratory bird
flying over state boundaries might
actually land in that puddle
that makes it subject to interstate
commerce interstate regulation because
so so that became if the the glancing
geese test wasn't the bird even looks at
it you know in a fond way well that you
know we get jurisdiction right
well that brings us to the sackett case
into a small bit of good news um
the sack it's for a family that bought a
nice lot near priest lake in northern
idaho zone residential surrounded by
other houses already
and they began preparations to build on
the lot including grading and filling
which you would do to get ready to build
a house
and that's when the epa arrived out of
the blue issuing what it called an
administrative compliance order which
not only said halt what you're doing but
take out on fill and restore the wetland
to its previous condition
the sackett said may we challenge this
determination that it's a wetland answer
from epa no you may not and by the way
if you don't comply
you face fines of up to seventy five
thousand dollars per day
uh
question here
that stat you know that fine level is in
the statute
but do we think that that 75 000 a day
fine meant to apply to small individual
lot owners or do you think it meant
dupont
i mean to ask the question is pretty
much to answer it right i don't think
congress would ever have approved a
clean water act if it thought that a
bureaucracy would be threatening a you
know a small individual landowner with
that kind of fine
the sacketts were further told that they
couldn't even challenge the
administrative compliance order
unless they ignored it and started
racking up the fines well that's a nice
you've got the gun to your head right
say you want to challenge our right to
use it right
hypothetically they could have been
liable for millions of dollars in fines
if they went that route and lost that
doesn't really sound much like due
process to me
well the case made it to the supreme
court the sacketts quite bravely
challenged it with the help of the
pacific legal foundation
and the supreme court ruled 9-0 the
current supreme court 9-0 against the
epa in this case
so not even the liberals were willing to
back up the supreme court uh back up the
epa's
direction in this case
and one of the problems that justice
alito wrote the majority opinion points
out is is there's so much uncertainty
and arbitrariness in what is a wetland
what isn't when is the epa going to step
in when are they not
and so he wrote in the opinion the
following
the combination of the uncertain reach
of the clean water act
and the draconian penalties imposed for
the sort of violations alleged in this
case still leaves most prop still leaves
most property owners with little
practical alternative but to dance to
the epa's tune
elita went on to say
something the court
doesn't do all that often does it sum
but it's really what he said was
congress needs to sort this out congress
needs to provide reasonably clear
jurisdictional rules to define what
waters really are
that make it subject to regulatory
control
here's his actual language
for 40 years congress has done nothing
to resolve this critical ambiguity
and the epa has not seen fit to
promulgate a rule providing a clear and
sufficiently limited definition of the
phrase
instead the agency has relied on
informal guidance
but far from providing clarity and
predictability the agency's latest
informal guidance advises property
owners that many jurisdictional
determinations concerning wetlands can
only be made on a case-by-case basis by
epa field staff
close quote that's the very definition
of arbitrary government i mean the whole
point of bureaucracy in the abstract is
that there will be uniformity and
predictability in the administration of
government and what you have here is no
predictability and no uniformity in the
administration of government that if not
arbitrary is maybe even uh can be
characterized as lawless government
by the way the epa is now working on a
new guidance document that
would simply re remove the word
navigable from its understanding of the
clean water act
so let's not even bother that that we'll
regulate anything we want to that's
essentially what that would mean
uh well what are the remedies for this
state of affairs
uh there are no simple ones
though there are a few innovations like
the reins act that ought to be tried out
now the reigns act
that's an acronym right stands for
regulations from the executive in need
of scrutiny
that and its twin the regulatory
accountability act that passed the house
uh in late 2011.
it won't pass the senate at least not
this senate um
so the reigns act would require that any
major new rules approved be approved by
a joint resolution of congress
and then sent to the president for a
signature in other words it would
introduce some political accountability
into the rulemaking process
in other words if the epa issued a
costly new rule like the boilermakt rule
it would be in effect a legislative
proposal
and the reins act would provide for
expedited procedures to bring it to an
up or down vote so it doesn't get lost
in committee hearings and some of the
usual midnight madness of
those folks over there
now the reigns act represents an
audacious reassertion of congressional
law-making prerogatives
and that's precisely why liberals and
environmentalists don't like it
but my argument is pretty simple
why shouldn't we make members of
congress stand and be counted on regula
on the record on regulatory proposals
that cost 100 million or more
even if that means it will take them
away from important things like naming
post offices or proclaiming national
orange juice week
borrowing that language from a friend of
mine actually um
the
second idea
requires some thought i'm just beginning
this thought which is
starting back in the reagan years
uh
you know sensible economist hillsdale
type people people across the street at
heritage
said one way to try and rein in
bureaucracy in general but especially
the epa is to have cost-benefit analysis
simple idea if the cost of a regulation
are greater than the benefits it
delivers we shouldn't do it
even though by the way some
environmental statutes say the epa like
the clean air act should not take
account of costs just only benefits in
the real world they do look at costs
some they're not complete idiots
however
the bureaucracy across the board and
especially the epa have gotten very good
at gaming cost benefit analysis cost
hardly any cost benefit's huge
and the office of management budget will
look this over and often pass on these
things even though any serious analysis
by the way they're always the size of a
phone book so they're daunting for
someone to get through and unravel to
point out how silly they are or how
ill-founded they are
but you know they bury you in paperwork
that's what bureaucracies are good at
and it's very difficult
and almost impossible to get a court if
you take these to court to to say that
an agency hasn't done cost benefit
analysis properly so cost benefit
analysis has been of limited use and
limited effectiveness and the always
protein bureaucracy has figured out ways
to adapt and go around it
so one question would be would there be
a way by statute
and or by executive order of a president
pay attention mr romney
to uh
to have an enforceable cost-benefit
standard that allowed for more
substantive judicial review
now that sounds like something that you
say why aren't you asking judges to
become expert economists no i don't
think they're i don't think it is
every once in a while you will actually
see a court take notice of one of these
things
and so there was an interesting case
last year at the court of appeals level
that caught my eye
it was called business roundtable versus
sec
the securities exchange commission so
what did these guys do
they'd issue a rule requiring that uh
when if your shareholder for company and
you get your annual report and your
ballot for board members
for an upcoming shareholders meeting
that the company must include materials
about the independent nominees who may
have been put forward for board
membership
now what was behind all this well this
was a rule by the sec to try to promote
representation by unions and state
pension funds and i'll i won't put too
fine a point on other troublemakers
right shareholder activists why should a
corporation have to pay
uh to promote the interest of its
enemies or its critics but that's what
the fcc was trying to get people to do
now
the authorizing statutes of the sec
require them to consider the economic
consequences of its rules
so there is a statutory provision that
has some legal force
uh
part of the language talks about the
efficiency competition and capital
formation the effects on those by these
proposed rules
so that amounts to a cost benefit
standard i didn't call it that in the
statute but it's there
so the court threw out this proposed
rule of the sec requiring that companies
have to pay for the promote the interest
of its critics
and the court said this in its uh
finding the commission inconsistently
and opportunistically framed the cost
and benefits of the rule failed
adequately to quantify the certain cost
or to explain why those costs could not
be quantified neglected to support its
predictive judgments contradicted itself
and failed to respond to substantial
problems raised by commenters
now it seems to me if we can do that
with the sec
we ought to be able to do that with
other agencies like the
epa
and that will lead me to one last reform
that i have heard no person suggests so
far
and
it's this
if you look back at
older regulatory agencies like the sec
the federal communications commission
the national labor relations board these
things that go back to the new deal era
nearly all of them have one thing that
marks them out is very different from
the epa two things really one is all
those agencies are single industry
agencies right the sec regulates the
financial world the labor relations
board labor unions and labor relations
the fcc communications the fda food and
drugs the epa regulates
who well just about everybody
there's another important difference
that makes this reform i think important
all those other agencies i mentioned
they typically don't have one
administrator at the top they have a
member they have a five-member board
appointed by the president but with
a sort of partisan balance that is to
say
uh they're appointed for fixed terms
right four or five years
the president appoints all of them but
but
two of the five members always have to
be from the party out of power in the
white house so the president gets to tip
the balance of power the epa has an
administrator
and the original statute authorizing the
epa gives amazing discretion to that
administrator to define all kinds of
broad terms which has led to a lot of
mischief we had
my reform is why not make the epa like
the fcc or the nlrb instead of an
administrator why not have five
environmental commissioners appointed by
the president
with minority party representation
in other words what people might say is
that would be putting politics back in
the epa and my answer is precisely
it's not a perfect solution i mean we're
following the mischief of the nlrb under
president obama but it would return the
epa into a political sphere and
introduce political accountability and
make for sharper partisan argument over
what the agency is doing on the
commissioner level
and as i said that's not a perfect
solution but that would be a significant
reform and i think changed the culture
of the epa dramatically if we did it
that way
as i say i haven't heard anyone make
that proposal but i think that's one
for one thing
i would just simply enjoy the the
screams of anguish from
environmentalists when that proposal
gets unveiled they'll absolutely go
berserk and it always makes my day you
know that's always fun it's not hard to
make them do that but that one's really
fun
so i think what i'm going to do
sort of one more point about this so
they say that's not a perfect solution
it's fitting that we're talking about
this seemingly narrow subject here at
the kirby center because what i said at
the very beginning is we need to have a
broad
theme or broad approach this problem
that really goes beyond the epa
so i'm teaching a one-week course uh of
this week over at aei for a summer
student program they do
that's on a subject very dear to the
heart of hillsdale college and the kirby
center it's a course on statesmanship
i'm trying to do in a week what
hillsdale college does in
well you know a year and some courses or
two years for the graduate program
you're starting right where is david
hiding
so hard hard subject to do but the point
is is that
it's pretty clear that at the end of the
day what is required for this and
similar problems is a higher degree of
constitutional literacy
by members of congress by citizens only
by everybody
and that means as a broad matter what
you need is more an intensive sustained
argument about some old basic principles
such as why property rights are human
rights every writ as much as free speech
and freedom of religion why the
separation of powers is an essential
bulwark of individual liberty that we
have allowed to slip away and needs to
be reestablished
you know we're all disappointed with the
outcome of the obamacare case quite
rightly for a lot of reasons that are
obvious on the other hand
two years ago no one thought there'd be
more than two votes
for certain for the position that the
commerce clause actually had a real
limit in it and we ended up with five
votes sort of as i say chief justice
john paul roberts as i call him i sure
hope stevens has sent him all his own
bow ties
right but there are five votes for that
position and we'll see if it leads to
something it's not clear
now whether that's you know a sort of a
pyrrhic victory on our side or not but
nonetheless
the lesson i draw from that is the
commotion over the constitutionality of
obamacare connected with tea party
activity was the most solitary
development in constitutional argument
in at least a generation so to that
extent
no matter how the case came out i always
thought that we were winning something
important even if we didn't get the
decision in the end and we lived to
fight another day in the election and in
congress and so forth but let not that
not be the end of this broad argument
about sort of constitutional literacy
and it's important not to get bogged
down too far into some of the
particulars of things like just the epa
or i didn't talk about the
administrative procedure act that really
gets off in the weeds but that probably
ought to be rewritten for modern times
and it's a very technical argument but
it's one that's very important but
even before or along with doing that you
want to as i say emphasize this broader
argument about what constitutionalism
means for a free people so i will stop
there and we can go on to questions and
comments and discussions
so you guys are gonna find people for me
is that how it's gonna work okay we now
have time for a few questions uh i would
ask that you would please wait until the
microphone has been brought to you to
ask your question
here's okay oh rj's got one back there
and there's one up here i think one of
the problems that i saw when
i was in air and radiation in the late
80s
was that a lot of the
the more radical greens who were there
on the staff and so on actually seemed
to have this belief that it was possible
to move into a world of zero emissions
they really did think that you could
find some sort of
make up some sort of green physics or
something in which you would transform
matter to energy without any byproducts
or whatever that and i think that's
still there i think the bmac thing sort
of shows that they just keep
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and they still won't stop yeah it's
pretty clear that the la did you was
that common equipment is that it or if
that was just a car yeah no i think i i
should have i should have been stronger
on that point in my comments it's not
just that the logic of bureaucracies is
always to keep going expanding we know
that from public choice theory and so
forth
i was talking to students yesterday i
think about
the quaintness of the progressive view
of 100 years ago that
you will have disinterested public
spirited experts in these bureaucracies
making decisions full of wisdom for the
public interest of course that's not how
it works out in real life you get as
hayek and others have explained you get
he didn't use the word fanaticism but
you combine utopianism
the sort of single-minded cultures of
bureaucracy you get in effect exactly
right ultimately the epa will not stop
until you get to zero
that's clearly the logic of the whole
thing some people believe it out of
wacko conviction
other people believe it because that's
just the nature of bureaucracies you get
very single-minded and that's the way
they go
so because you see that in other
bureaucracies and their equivalents
right
you know you
financial regulation you can see how it
works in some of those areas um it's
right so this is um
uh
i think we need to understand more
people need to understand that there's
no such thing as a disinterested
bureaucracy right
full stop
this gentleman had a question i think or
well whatever
either one i don't whoever you're closer
to
honest mike i just uh found it
particularly poignant that you use the
term erosion to describe what's
happening to our property rights
but uh on the subject of erosion i could
use termites federal termites too
it's uh
it's apparently the the now i don't know
if it's a virginia epa or federal epa is
now requiring that you fence in all
streams that cross grazing land
and i wondered if you would comment on
that and and how that relates to your
thoughts on imminent domain
oh well
um
as you all hear the question it was
about you know requiring fencing on
on grazing land that crosses streams and
yeah well so here's the problem
one way of thinking about the the
technical aspects of the problem of
water pollution is
we've pretty much built all the
wastewater treatment plants that we can
i mean there's a few out there that can
be upgraded and whatnot
and you know no chemical company dumps
stuff just straight into a river much
anymore without it being treated or so
forth
but you know we still have some water
pollution problems of uncertain
magnitude by the way our monitoring of
water quality is pretty abysmal we're
slowly getting better at it but we're 20
years behind where we ought to be
that said so the problem now is a sort
of runoff from fields streets all kinds
of things
now the regulatory solution is
what you propose except on everything in
other words
so we had this episode here a few weeks
ago was the epa using drones to spy on
people well no they're actually using
black helicopters
they're actually using planes with
pilots and you know they're taking
aerial photographs you can do satellite
photographs too so
and
clearly the logic is well we're going to
regulate every farm field in the country
this can't possibly work because there
aren't enough regulators to enforce that
plus
because every piece of land is a little
bit unique
a uniform regulation will get things
wrong
80 percent i'm going to guess 80 of the
time maybe not but
the point is you know an old tailpipe
regulation on a car or an effluent
standard for a wastewater treatment
plant that makes some sense you can
figure that out
but some kind of uniform regulatory
standard which is what bureaucracy does
that can't possibly work for regulating
water runoff with all the different
hydrological conditions in a big country
like this but that is what they want to
do so what you mention is um you know
fencing off
grazing land or you know creating
buffers against streams
in many individual cases that may make
good sense
um in the fullness of time it seems to
me you're going to want to think about
some technical solutions
and also i think ultimately what you
need to rely on is the incentives and or
best practices and judgment of
individual landowners
to persuade them that's in their
interests the interests of their
neighbors to think about things they
might do to reduce runoff into streams
from their animals and so forth that's
it so in other words to restate it the
basic problem is r.j and others have
pointed out for years of endangered
species act is it it's the incentives
backwards right you wake up one morning
david talked about it you see a kangaroo
rat in your land but the fish and
wildlife service hasn't been there yet
what do you do
you shoot shovel and shut up exactly
this is completely wrong right
so let's do this with let's do the whole
thing with water right let's tell
everybody everywhere we're going to be
after you
and what do you think you're going to
say no so you know you have the entire
farming sector and ranchers around the
country in an uproar about what may be
coming out quite rightly so and neither
the environmental movement nor the epa
has the imagination to step back and say
maybe we've got to think about a
different way to go after this that
doesn't make this adversarial and
punitive and they don't because by the
way they're you know a lot of the
environmental movement is life is no fun
if it's not adversarial punitive i mean
that's i mean i'm not that's not a joke
actually right um
and that's you know there's some the
extreme ones are hostile ideologically
to private property anyway
uh this is a general matter and so it's
not simply a matter they're just dumb
they're also malicious in a lot of ways
too so this is a big problem and this
fight's going to go on a while
and you know if you're actually
seriously interested in environmental
protection this is a disaster
because those problems are genuine and
they deserve some attention and some
significant remedy but not at the cost
of producing people's property rights
their rights to make a living
and not at the cost of having an army of
new bureaucrats running around
making a mess of things long speech but
that's my opinion
so
yeah
i'll make two apologies in advance
before asking this question one i'm
sorry if you feel that you've already
answered it in two right i'm sorry if
it's
uh if it demands an answer far too
lengthy for what you can deliver here um
but basically the question is
uh what do you think is the
proper
broadly speaking the proper conservative
environmental approach because i know
that you and people like roger scrutin
have been
agonizing in recent years over well that
may be too strong a word but
you've certainly been working to
attempt to take back an issue that i
feel the left is sort of almost
monopolized because it's far easier for
it to um
so
uh could you if you could please
i mean in the time that we have sketch
out what you think broadly would be the
proper conservative environmental
approach uh yeah i can do that sort of a
brief outline that's not hard to do yeah
i mean i'd like to say a couple of
things
this is part series with part
mischievous i like to say the
environment is much too important to be
left with the environmentalists
they just
they just screw it up right by making it
all bureaucratic and by the way that's
even true from their own point of view
just assume for a minute you're kind of
a i'll just say radical
environmentalists
uh
well right now this the politics
environment is such that there is no
possibility of any legislation they
would like getting through congress
i mean they're all depressed that cap
and trade didn't pass that was our own
darn fault and it's their darn fault
that that um
i like to make this point environmental
i really bust their chops about this i
said so the first president bush forget
president george w bush okay you didn't
like him the first president bush makes
the reauthorization of the clean air act
a major legislative priority goes to rio
and commits us to the u.n framework on
climate change a bad idea he still does
it uh you know he pushes hard on the
wetland stuff he does two or three other
things he appoints william riley head of
the epa who is pretty far the left how
many environmental groups endorsed him
for re-election in 1992
zero point i accused him of bad faith
and partisan bad faith why do you guys
want to be an adjunct the democratic
party how's that working for you
i have fun with that but there's a
broader point to all that the second
point is this is where roger scrutin and
i are we have some disagreements he's
he's hung up on plastic bags and he
shouldn't be but anyway
um but he does get this right if you've
seen his book property rights ought to
be the cornerstone of it
do you know the lectures why does no one
ever wash a rented car
right they don't own it right people who
own stuff tend to take care of it it's
true of landowners by the way for the
most part
there's some there's always some
negligent land owners just as there's
some people who don't wash the cars they
own okay fine
property rights
genuine markets
but also understanding that and this is
roger's point i agree with it is that at
the end of the day
we improve our environments as the
environment as individuals
by the choices we make and by actually
caring about it and the great phrase
roger uses i like is that the problem
with conventional environmental thinking
is it has confiscated these issues and
transferred them to government
and it actually makes us irresponsible
right when you confisc by the way this
is
true in a broader domain when you
confiscate risk from people
is it actually lower risk or increase it
you all may know the story about all the
research starting in the 60s and then
again with air bags in the 80s
the first generation of seat belt
wearers and the first generation of
people with airbags
suffered fewer injuries and crashes
absolutely
caused more crashes
you follow what i'm saying here you know
why that happened because people
intuitively thought oh my risk is lower
because i now have seat belts and
airbags so they actually cause net more
harm until we all had airbags and seat
belts going right
something that same dynamic happens in
the environment if you turn it over and
say it's the government's job
solely and primarily um
uh you know it leads to kind of an
environmental illiteracy and
so you know again the broad theme is
environmental citizenship is not a crazy
idea if we can keep the environmental
movement from spoiling it
i can say more but i'm going to stop
there and
room for a couple more questions we
actually have a question from our online
audience
michelle asks can you please comment
more on the effect that epa regulations
have on business how serious is the
threat of regulatory uncertainty
oh jeepers that's sort of a hard
question to ask without sort of getting
into specifics well i'll just say it's
it's can be huge because you've got to
get your permits
i'll just mention one case study that's
interesting
so the clean air act says
it
part of it reads this way there's more
there's always more to it the clean air
act says
if you emit a hundred pounds a year of a
pollutant you have to get a permit from
the epa or you're subject to the permit
process
well a hundred pounds of a volatile
organic compound that contributes to
ozone that's a lot
but a hundred pounds of co2 which the
supreme court said the epa can regulate
under that stupid decision a few years
ago well that's mcdonald's
are we really going to ask every
mcdonald's every burger king in the
country now to get a permit from the epa
someone the epa actually did an analysis
of this and said what would they say are
you remember this we need they need to
hire 200 000 regulators
at the epa to process the permits for
all the facilities it would be this
building would have to get a permit i'm
sure this building emits because it's
use of natural gas electricity accounts
for 100 pounds of co2 it's not very much
by the way you know each one of us here
you know how much you emit of just
breathing every year it's about 800
pounds
as an individual
so you know 150 of us get together we
might need a permit
so the epa by the way is trying to say
well we're not going to do that good for
them they're going to set the threshold
at 25 000 pounds except that's not what
the statute says the statute says 100
pounds
and the first time an environmental
group runs the court and says to a judge
the epa is not enforcing the law we want
them to enforce permits down to 100
pounds
judge is going to look at it and say yup
you're right epa you got enforces on
everybody that's what the statute says
environmental movements all ready to do
that at some point they're going to pick
their time if this really goes forward
so there's a huge threat of this crazy
greenhouse gas business going through
and the dc circuit court of appeal is
what two weeks ago punted on the issue
and once again said we're not going to
get in the middle of all this we're not
going to question epa's findings and all
this
so it's a it's a huge question mark
about this right now how this is going
to work if it really goes forward
so that's just one area there's more to
be said
right behind you
um
two things about the epa and then a
question uh back in the 80s somebody
came over to heritage they worked at epa
and said that the agency was hiring by
quotas which at the time i believe was
illegal and then this and that was a
reagan under the reagan administration
and the second thing is a person i knew
that worked there was a just out of law
school a year or so and he bragged to me
how how important his job was because he
got to write the laws
you know that the the uh congress
typically will write a general thing
clean up the air and then the epa goes
and they writes every other thing you
know
all the details
myriad laws
so the question is how much
authority does a president really have
over an agency if reagan couldn't
prevent quotas right and if uh if could
could a romney or and and did a bush
ever
succeed in having the epa
do away with some of these more more
stringent and uh costly
rules that's a huge problem because
these agencies tend to run on economic
on automatic pilot
the last bush administration tried to
constrain the epa in a few places
or try a different approach they had
their clean air interstate rule idea
that you know never mind the details and
they kept getting swatted down in court
because the the environmental laws were
written to give a hunting license to
environmental groups to get the way they
want to get what they want from judges
but let me
this is not on the epa specifically but
the second comment of yours is hugely
important
and maybe i should have said something
about it and i'll use it this way
because it's more fun
congress does not pass laws anymore they
pass to-do lists and wish lists and
that's even true of obamacare
so i actually thought when speaker
pelosi then speaker pelosi said you'll
have to pass the act to find out what's
in it that was the most intelligent
thing she ever said
now she didn't know it was and she
didn't mean it the way we mean it
but
uh we have now found out well you know
that this was perfect for a twitter
blurb right is we now know what's in the
law a tax
right
many taxes right uh but look so
obamacare we're up to 13 000 pages and
counting of regulations right regulation
is a long word for law that chap was
telling you i get to write the law
congress doesn't write the law it writes
these broad statutes of aspiration clean
up the air give us health care and has
language that says the administrator
shall do x the administrator shall
figure out why the administrators shall
determine what level is healthy
right that's one of the big problems
right now is the epa gets to set its own
targets not congress um
so with a couple of exceptions um so
this is a huge problem and this gets
back to you i did sort of make a bleak
reference to this saying about
delegation of authority to the
bureaucracy
and that's a violation the separation of
powers in my mind and that's one of
things we have to argue against across
the board not just on
epa not just on obamacare it's happening
with dodd-frank
happening in a lot of areas and it's
been going on for a long time and
you know finally people are starting to
say hey more and more people are
starting to say not just us
sort of cranky conservative scholars
more and more people are starting to say
hey wait a minute something's out of
whack here we got to rethink all this so
that's good at least there's more of a
fight a foot than there's been for a
long time
someone else yeah a lady here in front
has a question
well let me get to a microphone because
we're actually wrong
well we're online though so this will be
our final question
okay
my son works for
an environmental firm called tetra tech
out it's out of san diego but he's in
the local office here
and of course they work for contractors
for epa um
he considers himself in an not in you
know a crazy environment he's a
biochemist so that's why he was hired
and he does work for for um
permitting for water in california but
he's very frustrated by the you know
working with epa
and i think
i think there's a lot of corruption
going on in there
and
so
there's corruption in different regions
and um and he's concerned about it
so i just wanted your opinion well
two thoughts to conclude we we saw that
spectacular case what a month or two ago
that armandera's guy who got caught on
tape saying you know i like to abuse oil
companies
this is really power corrupting right um
i mean that's sort of an old-fashioned
kind of corruption
there's i'm i have no doubt uh that
there's the kind of really even more
insidious corruption where
you know if you're a company i mean i'm
not
i'll make a hypothetical i don't know if
this happens but it's the kind of thing
that does happen
and they find out oh you're a donor of
the heritage foundation
you know have you got your permit up to
date things like that happen um
maybe not herod but i think you know you
do you sign a petition if you send a
letter complaining to something um
i shouldn't say too but this is supposed
to be deeply off the record but i do
know
a situation right now where someone who
is making a public fuss gets a call from
his government federal regulations in
the last two weeks call from his federal
regulator the next day saying why are
you doing this
well that's not a friendly phone call
just a hi how are you
right this is a this is a huge problem
this is what our revolution was about
right the other point though about so
your son works for an environmental
consulting firm frustrated by the epa
in general
i guess i'll say in general and i sort
of troll around a bit and try and pay
attention to a couple of things like
that
people out in the private sector and
also a lot of academics who are
scientists
and
they're not especially ideological they
may be sort of conventionally liberal
the way academics would be
but
they're not especially hard
cardiological and environmental way and
they're very frustrated and
disillusioned with the environmental
movement they have no place else to go
is the problem and they're isolated
and it's hard to do i've thought for a
long time about is there a way these
folks could be organized into some kind
of alternative and i don't know if there
is or not be hard to do labor intensive
cost some money
and and also by the way there you know
i can tell you i've invited some you
know sort of distinguished environmental
scientists from places like duke's
nicholas school which is one of the
preeminent academic outfits and
they're a little nervous to come to aei
see so some of these people sort of nerd
what's going to happen to them if they
hang out with people like me
no they really do worry about let's have
a reputation and you know if they're
especially if they're not tenured
talk about academics um
so i i think there is the you know what
you know nixon used to call the silent
majority i don't know if it's quite that
but i think it may be something like
that there are actually a lot of
sensible people you know engineers out
there people who understand trade-offs
inherently because they are trained in
science and not in law
environmental law and stuff like that uh
and don't hang out with the
environmental groups
the environmental organizations i like
to point out are extremely rich
right i just take the nrdc its budget is
bigger than the combined budget of aei
heritage cato and the hoover institution
put together
the total budgets for all for those
organizations just one environment is
bigger than so there's like 500 people
in our dc they get their money from
direct mail and guilty hollywood
liberals
and that makes them very insular
actually
and
corrupt
in both senses intellectually and i
think actually in some cases i think you
can find that out um
and so they don't have any idea how much
they actually alienate a lot of people
in the middle but they have the
megaphone they have media sympathy and
so that's not going to change anytime
soon unfortunately so it's a tough
situation but you should be more
cheerful than that for the last answer
but
but i'll stop there and thank you all
very much
thank you very much steve and for those
of you who are interested in uh hearing
more
you can
follow the blogging i don't know if if
dr hayward tweets but uh he does blog at
powerline uh you can also see the
response that he made to al gore's an
inconvenient truth a full length uh uh
response uh uh that goes in in some
detail to uh providing a rejoinder to
the to the contentions in that
i'll invite you all now to uh to lunch
uh many of you have been here before and
know that it's served downstairs uh
there are elevators as well as stairs
directly below us here where you can get
a box lunch even if you have to depart
and get back to the office we invite you
to uh to grab and go
the
whole building is open for you too it's
a lovely day outside if you'd like to
eat outside on the 4th floor terrace or
or anywhere else feel free to do so i'll
mention one event that's coming up
the month of august we do not have this
lecture series
but we'll resume again in september
you'll receive email notification of
that it will be on or around september
11th and uh likely will focus on uh
remembrance of of
that
that day and issues attendant to it
the next event that we we do have
scheduled though is war and remembrance
the story of the american battle
monuments commission this is from a very
interesting uh perspective one of the uh
outstanding historians at hillsdale
college and indeed recently named uh one
of the 300
top professors in the country by
princeton review tom connor will be
presenting this it's part of an ongoing
research project
he leads many
hillsdale student and other trips over
to those battlefields and i think you'll
appreciate his perspective on this
largely uh unknown i think to the
american people's story of just what
this commission does and how important
its work is in preserving our memorials
to our fallen soldiers overseas
i'll close by mentioning steve talked
about twitter we do tweet and you can
follow the
the kirby center online and also like us
on facebook so with that please enjoy
lunch and the rest of your day